we're joined Now by Petro poroshenko the
former president of Ukraine and thank
you very much for being with us and
first of all I just wonder what you make
of the decision to call up 300 000
reservists
is there great evidence about how
powerful is the Armed Forces of Ukraine
how impressive is the unity of Ukraine
and Ukrainian people
and how important is the international
solidarity and international Partners
who support Ukraine by weapons Finance
sanction and everything because if Putin
and the most important thing the Putin
is a lie because when Putin said that he
lost only 6 000 soldiers in Ukraine
which is not true because it's
definitely more than 150
000. including 50 more than 50 000
killed that's why why if he lost only
six thousand he tried to uh enrolled
more than three hundred thousand and
with that situation uh it's another
important detail that there is they make
it secret and confidential the exact
number they plan to mobilize Point
number two this is if the Russian
soldier species on the contract Services
cannot do anything within 210 days of
the war why the people who would be
forcedly mobilized can do anything else
so this is the demonstration that we
must be vigilant this is the
demonstration that their Putin is in a
deep crisis and he start to understand
that the war he's losing the war and
with that situation he tried to rise in
up temperature he tried to rising up uh
bets and the whole world now is uh not
uh doing something with that and how we
can save the world well let me just let
me just ask you this about his threat to
use nuclear weapons if what he considers
Russia is attacked and I say if he if
what he considers Russia is attacked
because these referendums after these
referendums he will consider those areas
in luhansken Donetsk and so forth son he
will consider those Russia and I just
wonder what how worried you are about
his threat of nuclear weapons in those
circumstances do you think that's what
he means
look first of all
we do not exist any referendum this is
not a referendum at all
second he can consider this territory as
Russia even now
this is just an evidence that he is a
crazy maniac
Point number three and this is extremely
important from the 24th of February I
stay all these time in Kiev or in the
front line in South and in the east
and I'm absolutely confident that
Ukraine share exactly this my feeling We
Do Not Afraid
We Do Not Afraid when Putin troops was
five kilometers from this place when he
tried to encircle the uh
this is the another evidence that he do
not control the danielsky region
region
and with this situation his campaign is
failing and how we the last attack that
he can use the nuclear weapons
We Do Not Afraid even the nuclear
weapons the nuclear weapons is not
helping him is not saving him but this
is completely destroyed or Putin and
putting a circle
so you won't stop your offensive
operations you are not intimidated by
this
definitely not uh again just yesterday I
returned back from the south and when I
speak with the three Brigade uh which is
in an encounter offensive operation on
the south they are full of enthusiasm
they have a high motivation despite of
the very severe fighting on the south we
definitely have some problem for example
problem of Russian Aviation we do not
have the at this particular point of the
front line we do not have anti-aircraft
knee cells we do not have the effective
jet fighter and they are just dreaming
first of all the soldiers just want to
thank our partners from United States
from UK from all the NATO member states
and the point number two that the uh
this is the good uh good reason to sign
for the new uh weapons with the from the
western part well
I was going to ask you that very
question how should the West react to
What Vladimir Putin has said
well if before I have
some Western States said okay we need to
calculate we need some time to make a
decision we have our internal political
problem we can just demonstrate no we do
not have this time
Putin just demonstrate that he is
fighting not with Ukraine he is a piping
not only with a major he's fighting with
a whole Western World with every single
you and we need now to to please help us
to save you and with that situation we
shouldn't hesitate to supply for US jet
fighter to supply for us anti-aircraft
missile not accepting any blackmailing
from putting Navy in military in energy
in food in any other sector and with
that situation we need more sanction
to limit Putin with the economic Finance
of the war we need membership in NATO
because Ukraine paid for that a huge
price with the lives of our soldiers and
with their tones of blood we need to
have to be sorry for saying that in
Great Britain but we definitely need to
be the member of the European Union and
with that situation the effective
cooperation in the security and Military
sphere definitely can deputyize Europe
can deputyize world can deputyize Russia
and with that situation extremely
important is this day when we have a
United Nations General Assembly and we
need to change the structure of the
United Nations security Council to take
out the beta right from the Russian
Federation because this is the country
terrorist this is the country aggressive
this is the uh Putin Circle for killing
lots of ukrainians and we need to expel
Russia from the security Council all
right Petro perochenko uh appreciate
your time thank you very much indeed